نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ازمه اخرى تشعل فتيلا
مواجهه جديده بين الجمهوريين ورئيس
الامريكي وتطرح العديد من التكهنات حول
مستقبل بعضنا السياسي في حال المساء الى
القضائيه ملف اكتشاف الوثائق السريه
لجوبايدن ليواصلوا طرح المزيد من الجدل
ومطالبات التحقيق هذه المره تتعالى بين
الجمهوريين وحتى من بعض الديمقراطيين خمسو
صفحات اضافيه عثر عليها في البيت او عثر
عليها البيت الابيض في منزل في ويل من
ولايه زوال سيتم احالتها لوزاره العدل في
المرحله المقبله هذه الصفحات تعود الى عهد
اوباما حين كان بايدينا ايضا للرئيس ومعها
يرتفع عدده مواد الحكوميه المكتشفه بعهده
بيضا الى 16
حتى اللحظه اصبحت هذه الوثائق موضوع
تحقيقات بوزاره العدل ذلك السلاحا لدعم
ترامب ومن بينهم رئيس مجلس النواب الذي حض
الكونغرس على التحقيق مع بيضا وفق مراقبين
فان رئيس بايدن قدم فرصه من ذهب للجمهور
خاصه بعد ان انتقد في وقت سابق ما وصفه
منعدام مسؤوليه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب لدى كشف الوثائق السريه التي احتفظ
بها في منزله في فلوريدا لكن مستشار بيضا
برروا ذلك وقالوا بان الاعتفاظ به كل هذه
الوثائق سببه المعالجه غير الصحيحه
للسجلات من قبل مساعديه رئيس الامريكي
الحالي حيث قاموا بتخزينها عن طريق الخطا
صحيفه بوليتكو المواد السريه التي تم
العثور عليها حتى الان تضمنت ملفات تحمل
تصنيف سري للغايه وتضم معلوماتنا حساسه
حتى او تم الحصول عليها من المصادر
الاستخباراتيه وتعلقت ايضا بالمذكرات حول
اوكرانيا وايران وبريطانيا
سي ان ان الاخباريه
[موسيقى]
مناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفي دائما
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه اهلا بكم
معك سيد توم سؤال مطروح بعد الكشف في
مرحله جديده عن وثائق سريه اخرى بحوزه
بايضا هل هذه الوثائق ستنسف مساعي بايضا
للترشح لولايه جديده تعتقد
اولا مرحبا لكي ستريم والدكتور وليد
الدكتور ولا المشاهدين الكرام هلا طبعا
ستؤثر على لانه هلا هذا هذه الوثائق
السريه حسب القانون الامريكي يعني في منها
وظائف بعد 25 سنه تلقى هذه السريه ومنها
يبقى لمده 75 سنه ولكن الشخص الوحيد
باستطاعاته ان يرفع السريه في اي مكان
وزمان هو رئيس الجمهوريه في ذلك الفتره
وكما نعرف منها الرئيس الحالي بان هذه
الوثائق ليس لديك اي صلاحيات حتى عندما
كان نائب للرئيس اوباما ان هو ان يرفع
عليها عنها السريه وياخذها الى منزلك
واليوم يقولون هنالك 12 دقيقه اما 15
دقيقه هل كل وثيقه هي 20 ورقه اما ورقه
بالفعل لم نعرف الحقائق وما هي السريه
الموجوده ضمن هذه
بالذات على الكونجرس الامريكي ان يدقق
فيها اكثر
وهنالك كان نوع من النفاق عند الحزب
الديمقراطي عندما يطالب بانه بمواجهه
الرئيس ترامب في السابق والرئيس ترامب كان
رئيسا واخذ هذه الاوراق وقال انا رفعت
السريه عنها ولكن لم نعرف كيف الرئيس
ترامب رفع اسريه في ذلك الوقت ولكن كان له
صلاحيات الكامله فموضوع الرئيس ترامب
يختلف كليا عن موضوع الرئيس الحالي بيضه
ويجب على الكونغرس بالترقيق في هذه الملف
يعتبر بان هناك نساء من الديمقراطيين في
تعاملهم مع هذه القضيه
بدون شكل من الجمهوريين وحتى عدد قليل من
الديمقراطيين بدا يقول ذلك ولكن قليل جدا
بينهم بين الجمهوريين رئيس مجلس النواب
الجديد كبن مارتن قال ان هذا نفاق عظيم
فعلا في طريقه التعامل من قبل الاداره ومن
قبل وزاره العدل مكان المكارت
وزاره العدل ومكتبه تحقيق الفيدرالي بانهم
يصلحون العمليه السياسيه لهم يسيسون كل
شيء هناك معايير مزدوجه وفي نفس الوقت
ايضا همم
سمعنا من رئيس لجنه
الاشراف همم وهي اللجنه التي ستقوم
بالتحقيق في مجلس النواب قومه وجنس عمر
وبالتالي فان همم انه ايضا قال ان ما
يخلقه حتى اكثر من الوثائق والوجود
الوثائق واكتشافه امر فعلا خاصه
اه ولكن يهمني رايك كذلك في هذه المرحله
وحضرتك مراقب دكتور ادموند كل هذه
التفاصيل رايك هل تعتبر بان هناك كيل
بمكيالين من الديمقراطيين تجاه هذه القضيه
وبانه هذه القضيه قد تحطم حلم بيضن رئاسه
جديده او لولايه جديده
[موسيقى]
نرى انه يتم تحقيق مع الرئيس السابق
للولايات المتحده وتعيين المدعيه عام
ليقوم بعمليه الاشراف على عمليات تحقيق
وكذلك نرى ان الرئيس الحالي الان هناك
مدعي عام يقوم بالتحقيق في ايضا الوثائق
التي لديه وهذه كل هذه امور غير غير
مسبوقه لم نرى شيئا مماثلا لذلك في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده سابقا بالتاكيد ان هذا
ايضا الامر يهدد الرئيسين السابق والحالي
طبعا هناك كانت هناك ازدواجيه في المعايير
بدون شكر طريقه التعامل مثلا تم ارسال
مكتب التحقيق قوه امنيه مسلحه للتفتيش في
منزل صحيح ما يقوله الديمقراطيون ان ااه
عفوا الرئيس ترامب همم ااا صحيح ان ما
يقوله الديمقراطيون هو ان ترامب لم يتعاون
معهم رفض لتقديم الوفاء هذه بين فعل عكس
عكس ذلك ويقول ولكن الجبوريين يقولون
الغرفه كانت مغلقه من قبل الاداره
المسؤولين الامنيين في الايات المتحده
سؤال لحضرتك استاذ
بعضه الجمهوريين همم
الديمقراطين كذلك ينادون بالمساءله
والجمهوريون من جهتهم ذهبوا لابعد من
داركم حتى يتحدثوا عن البحث وراء قائمه
زوار مختلف منازل
هل يمكن ان يحدث ذلك
يجب ان على الرئيس بايدن ان يسلم
اللجنه في الكونغرس الامريكي
لائحه كامله بمن زاره في منزله لانه ما
كان يروح مره كل شيء شهرين ثلاثه كان يذهب
كل اسبوع ويلاقي اشخاص سياسيين هنالك
وغيرهم يعني راح بنسبه له بالرئاسه سنتين
وشهر تقريبا
25% من وقته بمنزله ولكن انا اللي اضيف
الى الدكتور كذلك عندما قاموا بدهم منزل
الرئيس السابق ترامب كنا قبل الانتخابات
النصفيه بشهرين وربما هذا الدعم وهذه
الموضوع الذي الاعلام الذي قام به
الديمقراطيين وحتى وزاره العدل اثرت على
نتائج انتخابات النصفيه وقبلها بسنتين كنا
شفنا كمان التواضع بين الحزب الديمقراطي
واعضاء من الاس بي اي مع التويتر ربما
كذلك اكثروا على الانتخابات 2020 ربما
اليوم يجب ان نكون شفافين اكثر
واللجان في الكونجرس بالتدقيق بهذه
الامكان بال2020 والتدقيق كذلك اليوم
بمداهمه الرئيس السابق ترامب لم نرى
مداهمه لمنزل الرئيس الرئيس
وخاصه كما علمنا من الاعلام حتى الان بان
كل هذه المعلومات كشفت من قبل محاميين
الرئيس
وهم غير مخولين بيتحمل المسؤوليه
[موسيقى]
تحمل مسؤوليه هذه الوثائق السريه
مهما تكون تفاصيل ونحن اكيد سنبقى في
انتظار مساء يرشح عن هذه التحقيقات ولكن
هل هناك احساس في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بان همم الحزب الديمقراطي في
ورطه في هذه المرحله خاصه وان تتذكر معنا
في فتره وثائق ترامب كانت هناك همم يعني
انتقادات بالجمله وكان هناك حتى انتقادات
اخلاقيه طالت ترامب وكان بايضن يبرز نفسه
على انه انسان مستقيم نزيه مهني لا يمكن
لانسان مسؤول ان يقترف مثل هكذا واقترف في
النهايه همم يعني همم الاثنين تقريبا
اقترفوا نفس
الانتهاك وبالتالي هل هذا يضر بصوره الحزب
يعتمد
المعلومات التي ستبرز من خلال همم
التحقيقات وذلك لان التفاصيل هنا همم هناك
تفاصيل كثيره وتفاصيل ولكنها مهمه همم
وبدون شاكر بدانا مثلا
همم
الرئيس اعترفت بان هذا محرج جدا للرئيس
محرج للاداره وبالتالي في هذا سيكون له
دعايات هذا يدفعنا باتجاه اخر ربما بعض
سيصفها ويمكن وصفاها بان قد تكون جزء من
عمليات المؤامره ولكن فعلا الاول هل هناك
رغوه من قبل بعض الجمهوريين في السابق
للشنطه خاصه في طريقه التي تعاملوا فيها
همم
مهمتان اولا انه ربما يريد ابعاد ترامب
منع ترامب وهذا ايضا ما يريده
الديمقراطيون ابعاد ترامب عن ترشيح نفسه
للانتخابات وهناك من يعتقد الان ان
التسريب والطريقه او ال- نابل الاكتشاف
هذه الامور والاعلان عن الان مع انه يقال
انه اكتشفت قبل كما ذكر الاستاذ حرب كشفت
قبل الانتخابات يوم في الثاني من نوفمبر
لماذا لم يعلن عنها عند ايضا او لماذا لم
يتم احراق
ان الرئيس
في وضع قوي لترشيح نفسه ولهزيمه
الجمهوريين ولذلك يريدون الضغط عليه
لاقصائه عن الترشيح هذه كلها نقاط مهمه
جدا
اذا كانت هذه النظريه صحيحه ام لا خلال
الايام القادمه
هل يمكن ان يكون همم اعلان عن هذه الوثائق
السريه هو نتيجه ناقصامات داخليه همم
يعيشها الحزبه قراءتي تعتقد
لنعرف ما الحقيقه يجب على اللجنه في
الكونغرس التدقيق والتحقيق في هذا الملف
وربما بعد خمس سته اشهر نعرف اكثر لانه ما
بدنا نفوت بموضوع المؤامره المشهورين في
نحن بالعالم العربي ولكن هنالك
مؤامره افشل هذه الاسرار في نهايه يمكن ان
تكون هناك همم طريقه سريه لافشاءها يقول
دكتور رائد موت في وقت المناسب هو يضع
نقاط استفهام حول التوقيت هل يمكن ان ياتي
هذا الموضوع نتيجه لي همم
قسام داخل الحزب
يعني نحن اذا بنرجع مع الدكتورمون من ست
سنوات حتى اليوم الوقت الرئيس ترامب
والترقيق بالمعم بقضيه روسيا والتامر مع
روسيه والقينا الحزب الديمقراطي حتى مع
المخابرات الامريكيه هو الذي قام بهذا
بهذه العمليه يعني اليوم صار كل شيء يصدق
ولكن بالفعل يجب ان ننتظر النتائج قبل
نقول شيئا غير ربما لا يكون هكذا ويجب ان
نكون حريصين ولكن الاثنان ربما سيتعرضون
لضغوطات من وزاره العدل لتمنعهم من اكثر
من
الاستكمال الترشيح لانه حتى اليوم هذا ما
بنعرف اذا الرئيس فيقود المعركه الرئاسيه
ولا لا ولكن نعرف بان الرئيس ترامب فيقود
المعركه الانتقاليه
الشكر منه اورلاندو توم حرب همم
رئيس رئيس تحالف الامريكي اوسطيه لا
الديمقراطيه من واشنطن الدكتور غريب
الاستاذ في العلاقه الدوليه شكرا لكم